>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Pam Jackson: So we have a
very special morning with you,
we're excited to share it.
We have, both here in the
room, very special guests.
And we also have some
friends of us that are going
to be online, live,
in a live stream.
So we have some friends from
Pennsylvania, and from Arkansas.
So I want to hear your
loudest voices,
were going to practice saying
"Hello Arkansas!", are you ready?
One, two, three...go!
[ children's voices ]
Hello Arkansas!
>> Pam Jackson: Alright,
great, and were going
to try one more time
with Pennsylvania.
Ready? So loudest voices,
this is your time,
you have permission to just be loud.
And then when Dr. Hayden actually
greets them, you'll be able to say
"hello" as loud as you want.
This is the one time needed
to be as loud as you want.
You ready for that?
>> [ children's voices ]
Yeah.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay, let's try it
one time with "Hello Pennsylvania".
Loud though, right?
I'm soft, you're loud.
Ready? One, two, three...
[ children's voices ]
Hello Pennsylvania!
>> Pam Jackson: Alright,
that's awesome!
>> Cokie Roberts: Okay Pennsylvania!
>> Carla Hayden: A
couple of states in there.
>> Carla Hayden: And, not only are
we going to be loud, and were going
to say "hello Pennsylvania"
and "hello Arkansas",
how about if we wave two?
Because see all these cameras?
They're looking at us.
Is that something?
So, Carla Hayden, and I'm
the librarian of Congress.
And I'm so excited that all
of you in, where, Arkansas?
Let's say it.
"Hello Arkansas!".
[ Childrens Voices ]
Hello Arkansas!
>> Carla Hayden: And,
"Hello Pennsylvania!"
[ Children's Voices ]
Hello Pennsylvania!
>> Carla Hayden: We're
glad everybody's here,
because this is a special month.
Does anybody know what month this
is, and what makes it so special?
And why, okay, this is March.
Right. It's March, and
spring is in the air.
Is also a month, that's called
"Women's History Month".
I know. An entire month, and
>> Cokie Roberts: Just a month.
>> Carla Hayden: Just a month.
But it's a good month.
It's a good month because we're able
to have special people to join us,
and today we have someone who has
been called "a living legend."
>> Cokie Roberts: Living.
>> Carla Hayden: Living.
She's still living.
[ laughter ]
>> Carla Hayden: All
because some legends,
as you know, are way in the past.
But we are so excited, Arkansas?
Can you hear us?
Yay! Let's say it again: Arkansas?
>> Audience: Arkansas?
>> Carla Hayden: Pennsylvania?
>> Audience: Pennsylvania?
>> Carla Hayden: Because
we have Ms. Cokie Roberts.
Now many of you know that
she has been in television
>> Cokie Roberts: Forever.
>> Carla Hayden: A long.
But she's still living!
>> Cokie Roberts: Living.
>> Carla Hayden: She's still living.
She has been with the National
Public Radio, ABC, you name it.
Ms. Cokie Roberts has
been part of talking
about what's going on every day.
And in the meantime she's
also been able to write books.
So I'm can ask you later how did
you do all of this at one time.
But she has two books.
One about-- have you ever heard
the term "founding fathers"?
You've heard that?
Did you know there were
"founding mothers"?
There were women that actually
helped with the country.
And now, a new book:
Ladies of Liberty.
So, you are here with Miss Cokie
Roberts, and I'm going to be
over here and listen
too, because she's going
to tell you about her book.
>> Cokie Roberts: Okay,
well first of all, yes.
A hand for Dr. Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Dr. Hayden is in
charge of this whole big building.
And the building across the
street, and other buildings
around the country,
that have every book
that was ever published in them.
How many books are in
the Library of Congress?
>> Carla Hayden: 38 million.
>> Cokie Roberts: 38 million books!
And movies, and records,
and paintings,
and musical instruments,
and all kinds of things.
This is where they all are.
So when you get a little bit bigger,
and you need to do some research.
Does anybody know what research is?
What's research?
Okay, go ahead.
>> [ inaudible response ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Where
you search for something?
Yeah? Usually for what?
Do you know why you'd be
looking for something?
>> Causes?
>> Cokie Roberts: Causes?
Well that's a good reason
to do research, yes.
But often to write a school
paper, or write a book,
and actually when I was in
school here in Washington,
I did a lot of my reseach here
in the Library of Congress.
So it's a great place to come and
learn about all kinds of things.
And in writing my books, these are
children's books, but I wrote grown
up books with the same names,
and I did a lot of my work here
in the Library of Congress
for those books.
But the reason I wrote those
books is because I kept looking
at pictures of day, the Declaration
of Independence or the Constitution
or things like that and I thought
"there's something
missing in these pictures."
Do you think there's
something missing?
What do you think's
missing in those pictures?
When you look at the pictures of
the folks writing the Consititution
or the Declaration of Independence?
What's missing?
Anybody have a guess
what might be missing?
Do you see?
>> Women.
>> Cokie Roberts: Women.
Right! There are no
women in those pictures.
None! So my question was:
"Were there women then?"
Do you think there were women then?
What do you think?
Let's see if some of the other kids
here, you think there were women?
>> Yes.
>> Cokie Roberts: Yeah?
How do you know?
There's no evidence.
We don't see any pictures of them?
How do we know there
were women then?
>> Because they were
making stuff for men.
>> Cokie Roberts: They
were making stuff for men.
They certainly were,
all kinds of things.
But, So I was very curious
about what they were doing.
Sine it was a very
important time in our country.
It's when the country
started to become a country.
And the first thing that had
to happen for the United States
to become the United States
was that we had to fight a war.
And we had a fight
a war against who?
Who did we have to fight against?
Guys? Who did we have
to fight against?
We fought a war called
the "American Revolution".
Right. And who was it against?
>> Russia.
>> Cokie Roberts: No not Russia.
It was against Britain.
And at that point we
were part of Britain.
We weren't our own country.
And the men and women who were here
said "We want to be on our own.
We want to be our own country."
And so they said "We're
going to tell Britian we want
to be our own country" and
they wrote something called
"The Declaration of
Independence" to say we're not part
of you any more we're independent.
But Great Britain said "Nuh
uh, you are part of us.
And we're going to show you,
you're going to have to fight
to be a separate country.
And so they fought us,
and we had a general
in charge during the American
Revolution, what was his name?
>> George Washington.
>> Cokie Roberts: George
Washington, exactly right.
And George Washington had a wife.
What was her name?
Hm? Anybody remember?
>> [ Inaudible Response ]
Cokie Roberts: Her name
was Martha Washington.
And every year the soldiers that
George Washington was leading went
to camp and they, it was the winter
time, it would be very, very cold,
and sometimes they
didn't have enough to eat,
and sometimes they didn't
have a place to stay,
and Martha Washington
would come into camp
and she an the other officers
wives would sew for the soldiers,
and cook for the soldiers, and
make up songs for the soldiers,
and have big dances for the soldiers
so that they would be happier
and they would stay in the army.
And so George Washington wanted her
to come every year even
though it was scary.
Because sometimes bullets were
flying and that wasn't a lot of fun.
But then, the country became a
country because we won that war
and George Washington became what?
>> The president.
>> Cokie Roberts: The president.
What number president?
>> The first.
>> Cokie Roberts: The
first president.
And Martha Washington
became the first First Lady.
And she had to figure out how to
do that, which was complicated.
And then, actually I should
tell you one of the years
that they were a camp during
the war, and this woman came
to visit George Washington and
her name was Phyllis Wheatley.
Has anybody ever heard of her?
Hm? She was a poet, she
was a very famous poet.
And she had been a slave.
She had been enslaved,
and she became free
and as a teenager she wrote
this poem that were so popular
that people in England
read about them,
and people in America
read about them.
So she was known on
both sides of the ocean,
and George Washington wanted to
meet her because she was so famous
and wrote such wonderful poems.
And so, when he was in camp in
Massachusetts she went to visit him
and he said she was
"gifted by the muse",
meaning she wrote such
beautiful poems.
But then he became president, the
country still needed some help
because there is a lot of work to
be done making it, a new country,
and the British came
again and were not happy
that we had become
a brand-new country.
And they were trying to take us
back, back to be part of Britain.
And so, there was another war.
And that one was called
the war of 1812.
And the British came
here to Washington,
and Dolly Madison was the
president's wife, the first lady.
You know what her husband's
name was, if she was Madison?
What was her husband's name?
>> [ inaudible response ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Dr. Hayden's
giving it away, James Madison.
And he had gone out to camp with
the soldiers, to see what was going
on in the field, and she
was at the White House.
And the British were coming.
And she went out on the
top of the White House,
with the spyglass they called
it, it'slike binoculars.
And she could see them
coming in the distance.
And she kept waiting for
her husband to get home,
and she had made a big dinner
for him, and for his cabinet,
and generals, and they were coming.
And she could see the
British coming.
And everybody said to her "you've
got to go, you've got to go,
it's getting really dangerous!
The British are coming!", and she
said "Well I'm not going to go,
until I make sure that the portrait
of George Washington is safe,
because the British will
do something awful to it."
so she made sure it was taken down
from the walls of the White House,
and safely taken away in a carriage
before she left the White House.
And so she escaped just as the
British arrived in Washington.
And they got here and they
started burning the city.
They burn the capital,
and they march
down Pennsylvania Avenue
burning things,
and then they got to
the White House.
You know what they did
before they burned it down?
They sat down in a
Dolly Madison's dinner.
And they said it was
a delicious dinner,
and that they were sorry
they had to do something
so awful to her, but they did.
And so after they finished
their dinner,
they took a torch and
lit the White House.
And since they didn't have George
Washington's picture to steal,
they stole Dolly Madison's picture
and took it with them as they left.
So then, the country
still had to be a country,
and they beat the British again.
And it was now clear
that we were going
to be the United States of America.
We were going to go on
and be a great country,
and we became a bigger country
because Thomas Jefferson had decided
to buy some land that would
double the size of the country.
Does anybody know what
that was called?
When you bought all that land?
It's called the Louisiana purchase.
And he asked a couple of
men to go see what was
on the land, see how big it was.
And they had an expedition, called
the Lewis and Clark Expedition.
And they needed someone,
they knew they'd be dealing
with Native Americans
as they went all the way
across the country
to the Pacific Ocean.
And they needed someone to
help them talk to the Indians.
So they went up to
an Indian settlement,
in what's now North Dakota,
then it wasn't a state,
and met a man who could speak
some of the native languages
and he was married to this woman.
Does anybody know who she is?
Anybody know who that is?
No? That's Sacajawea.
And she was a young Indian
girl who, right before they set
out on this big expedition
to go all the way
across the country, she had a baby.
So she had to do this
with her baby on her back.
There's the baby.
And as they set out on their
expedition they realized Sacajawea
new all kinds of things
that nobody else knew.
She knew how to find all kinds of
fruits, and berries, and vegetables
that were hidden in the soil,
so she could help everybody eat.
And when there was a bad
flood, because they were going
by river most of the way, and the
boats were swamped with water,
she saved a lot of the provisions.
And the men who wrote
about it, Louis and Clark,
said she was wonderful, and her
husband was totally useless.
But she had did all this
was the baby on her back!
And she was only probably
15 years old.
But she still did this
incredible walk across the country.
But at some point they
knew they were going
to hit big, tall mountains.
And what would they need to
get them across the mountains?
The boats weren't going to get
them across the mountain, right?
>> [ Inaudible Response ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Well it
wasn't skiis so much will.
>> A stick.
>> Cokie Roberts: A
stick would help,
but what would carry
them across the mountain?
>> [ Inaudible Response ]
>> Cokie Roberts: You can
do that for rope climbing,
but what would you ride across the
mountain back in the olden days?
>> A sled?
>> Cokie Roberts: No,
it would be a sled.
Go ahead.
>> Horses.
>> Cokie Roberts: Horses.
They needed horses.
And the people who had horses
where the Native Americans.
And the Shoshone tribe was
known to have the best horses.
And when they reached
the Shoshone's,
out in what is now probably Wyoming,
Sacajawea who was a
Shoshone said "Oh!
My brother has become the
chief since I've been away!"
and she was so excited to see him,
and see all of her old friends,
and then she worked it out so
Lewis and Clark got the horses.
They treated them for some
ammunition, and off they went
across the mountains and got all
the way the to the Pacific Ocean.
But right before they got to the
Pacific Ocean, they set up camp
and the men were going
to go see The ocean.
And Sacajawea said "That's not fair!
I've come all this way with you,
and I've guided you along the way
and shown you how to go,
and gotten you these horses,
and you're not letting
me go see the big water?
That's not fair!"
and they said "You're right", and
so she went with them to see it.
And then she guided
them back all the way
across the country to
St. Louis, Missouri.
And when they got there, Clark wrote
that she should have done a
bigger reward then she got,
because she had been so
important to what they were doing.
Well she sure should have, because
you know what her reward was?
Zero. So it was not fair to her,
but she had a very
interesting experience,
and then William Clark
helped raise her son,
the baby who had been on her back.
But, while the country was moving
west, and everybody was excited
to have this very brave new country
where they could have a new life
and start off new farms, for
new businesses all on their own,
there were some people
who were doing as well.
In some of them were poor,
and some of them were widows,
women whose husbands had died.
And some of them were children whose
parents had died, who were orphans.
And the women looked around
and saw that, and said we need
to do something about that.
And so one of them was a
woman named Isabella Graham,
and she was a widow
herself, her husband had died
and she had four little children,
and she moved to New York,
and she opened a school for girls,
and she made some money
on that school.
So that then she was able to do
what she really wanted to do,
which was help for people.
So she started with other women,
one of them was Eliza Hamilton,
anybody know who her
husband might have been?
Alexander Hamilton was her husband.
And one of them was
Elizabeth Bailey Seddon.
You go to Seddon School?
Yeah. And one of them was Mother
Seddon,, who I'll tell you
about as well, she's got
a big story in this book.
Here she is, so that's your school.
This is the woman that
your school is named after.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> [ Inaudible question ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Her
husband was dead.
I'll tell you her story
just a minute.
So these women got
together and said "we have
to help the children of New York".
So they started an orphanage
which was really hard to do,
because they didn't have the right
to vote, women couldn't vote,
until not even 100 years ago.
And this is more than 200 years ago.
And they couldn't even own property.
Their husbands had on their
property if they were married.
But they were brave, and they went
to the people who ran the state
and said "we need an
orphanage, you have to help us.".
And then they went out into
the streets, and had meetings
of the public and said "we need an
orphanage, you have to help us".
And they started an orphanage,
and it still in New York
today, helping children.
It's not an orphanage anymore,
children don't live there,
but it still helps the
children of New York.
So even without any rights
these women did incredible work
that has been lasting.
And, Elizabeth Bailey Seddon,
at your school's named
after was one of them.
So she left New York,
because her husband was sick,
and they went to Italy hoping he'd
get well in Italy, and he died.
And so she came back to America,
because she had five children,
and she came back with no money,
and she went to Baltimore
and opened the school.
And the Bishop of Baltimore said
"We need you to open more schools".
And so she opened more, and more,
and more schools all
over the country.
And she opened orphanages
as well, and hospitals,
and she did incredible
work, all over the place.
Because these children and
poor people needed her,
and she just said "I'm
going to do it."
and it was really hard
work but she did it.
We also had in this time some first
ladies, and one of them was the wife
of the president who was the son
of President Adams,
and his name was what?
Anybody know the name of
the son of President Adams?
Who was also a president.
>> John Quincy Adams?
>> John Quincy Adams.
And his wife is the only other
First Lady, other than Mrs. Trump,
to have been born outside
of the United States.
Her name was Louise Catherine
Adams, and she was born in England
where her father was working for
the United States in England.
That she had never been to America
when she married John Quincy Adams.
And she came, and she was
very involved in politics.
And her father-in-law, who had
then president, John Adams,
she wrote to him and
said "it is my job-- -
my vocation was the word she was--
my job to get my husband
elected president."
Now people don't think
women were involved
in politics then, they're wrong.
The women were very, very
involved in politics.
And she worked to get her
husband elected president,
and she succeeded.
But she also worked with
the women here in Washington
to help the poor children.
Because after the British had
invaded, they needed help as well,
and there is an orphanage started
by the women here,
and it still is going.
Again, nine orphanage anymore, but
helping children in Washington.
That's Hillcrest.
So these women did incredible
things, and they were very,
very interested in making sure that
the country was a better country.
It was a great country!
But they wanted it to
be a better country.
And so then, they started looking
around and seeing the things
that it's not just people that
were poor, but there are people
who were enslaved, and they
thought that was the wrong thing.
And so they started working
for freedom for the slaves.
And then they started going to
those meetings about freedom
for the slaves, and they discovered
that they weren't allowed to talk,
because they were women, and
they weren't allowed to vote,
because they were women,
and it made the mad.
And so, then they started working
for women to have the right to vote.
So the two great big things that
have happened in this country
to make a better country,well,
lots of things have happened,
but the two great big things:
ending slavery, and making sure
that everybody could vote,
started very, very early.
And it started with the women.
So that's why I call them
the "Ladies of Liberty",
because they made this happen.
So I'm really happy to share
them with you today and I'm happy
to take your questions, if
you have some questions, okay?
[ applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: And we also
want to thank "Everybody Wins".
That's a group that made sure
that Miss Roberts was here,
so please thank Everybody Wins,
you see the wonderful sign?
Because everybody wins?
When we read together.
So you can ask questions,
and we had questions
from Arkansas, and Pennsylvania too!
>> Cokie Roberts: so
that's exciting we'll hear
from the other kids as well.
So somebody had a question
back here, sir?
I think he's turned around.
You had a question.Yeah.
Kay.
>> When he was in this book maded?
When was it published?
Today? Or a long day ago?
>> Cokie Roberts: Not
a long time ago.
It was just published this year,
and I should have told you a little
bit more about the illustrations.
Because the woman who drew the
pictures did a wonderful job,
her name is Diane Good and
she drew great pictures
of all of these women.
And when she was doing the first
book, this one came out first,
and it was a couple of years ago.
She got very interested
in all of their writings,
not just what they wrote, but how
they wrote: their handwriting.
And she got an old-fashioned--
but call a quill, that's what they
wrote with, it had a little point
in the end-- and she started writing
with that just like they did.
And she lives in New Jersey,
and then Hurricane Sandy hit,
and she didn't have any
power, so she was in the dark,
and had to draw by candlelight.
So she really knew how they felt,
and she got so interested she said
to me "Do you think we
could we could find all
of their signatures?", And so I
said "gee, that's gonna be hard".
Because it's really
hard to find out things
about women a couple
of hundred years ago.
But, I did.
I found all of their signatures.
So under each of the pictures
is how they wrote their name.
And I teased her that
she did such a good job
at copying how they
wrote their names,
that she should be a
counterfeiter in her next job.
Okay. Yeah?
>> Will you have the Lady of
Liberty in other libraries?
>> Cokie Roberts: Yes!
It's in libraries all around
the country, I'm happy to say.
>> You were just talking about
all of the important ladies,
are those the only
ladies in the book?
>> Cokie Roberts: So in
the book, the publisher,
the people who publish the book,
one in 10 ladies in each book.
So I picked 10 for each book.
And so there are people from
different parts of the country,
and there are people of
different races in both books.
>> Question.
>> Cokie Roberts: Yes.
>>We have a question from
Pine Road Elementary School,
which is in Pennsylvania.
Remember you guys said
"hi Pennsylvania"?
So lots of kids in the fifth grade
have a question, so Joel, Valentina,
acqlyn, Abdullah, all want to know:"
why did you decide to write a book
about women who helped
form this country?"
>> Cokie Roberts: Well because
I thought it was important
that we know about them.
You know it's my view that
if you only know about half
of the human race, and not the
other half of the human race,
you don't know the whole story.
And it's not even really
accurate, it's not exactly true
if you only know about
half of the human race.
So I thought that it
was very important
that we know the whole story,
and what everybody was doing
to create this country and make it
the wonderful country that it is.
We have another one from there?
>> Carla Hayden:We
actually just have a tweet,
that Shelley Porter is excited
that Mrs. Johnson's fourth
grade class is participating
with a class from Arkansas.
>> Cokie Roberts: well
that is exciting,yay!
[ applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts: So,more
questions here?
Right here.
>> Pam Jackson: We have one more.
We have one from Arkansas,
Crossett Elementary school.
And Cameron wants to know--
who is in fourth grade--
which lady of liberty was
your favorite to write about?
>> Cokie Roberts: The people always
want to know who my favorite was.
In the truth is, I don't
really have a favorite.
Because they were all very
different from each other.
And some of them would have been
a lot of fun to have dinner with,
I think that, let's see,
in this book I would say
that Louisa Adams would've
been fun to have dinner
with because she had
a good sense of humor.
And some of them I would
have just admired greatly,
like Elizabeth Seddon,
who I told you about.
And some of them I would have
been very interested to just get
to know because of the writings.
This woman, Judith Sargeant
Murray, wrote way back in the 1700s,
she wrote that women
should be equal.
And so this picture of the
scales, with the little boy
and a little girl on the scales
at the same level, she wrote
and said "Does anybody
look at a two-year-old boy,
and a two-year-old girl, I
think that the boy is smarter?"
What do you think?
Huh? No? No.
So what happens?
So what happens, in that
time girls weren't educated.
So she said girls needed to go
to school, and become educated,
and they could do anything
the boys could do.
I would've loved to getting to
know her, and know why she thought
that so early, when other
people weren't thinking
about it so much yet.
So different ones I like for
different reasons.Yeah, go ahead.
>> Did any one of them,
in each book,
did any one of them inspire
you to do anything like this?
>> Cokie Roberts: well, actually,
what they've inspired me to do is
to not say I can't do something.
Because they did things
that are really hard
with much less ability to do them.
They didn't have computers, and
they didn't have dishwashers,
and they didn't have all the
things that make our lives easier.
And terrible diseases
were around at the time.
So sometimes I'm on could
lose two children in a week,
and it was unbelievably sad.
And still, they would do
things for the country.
Not just for themselves,
not just for their family,
but they would do things
for other people even
when they were having a
very hard time themselves.
So it's made me realize
I can't say "oh,
it's too hard", that's
just sissy talk.
I have to be able to say "of course
I can do it, these women did it".
>> How did you feel
when you wrote Ladies
of Liberty, and Founding Mothers?
>> Cokie Roberts: it was
really nice to finish them.
Writing a book is hard, and writing
the grown-up books was very hard.
And one of the reasons it's
hard to read about women is
because as I was saying
earlier it's not easy to find--
I talked about research, remember?--
it's hard to research them
because people haven't
saved a lot of their things.
How do you think we
learn about history?
What do we look at?Yeah?
>> Encyclopedias.
>> Cokie Roberts: encyclopedias
help, but the encyclopedias have
to go to some place to learn.
So where else might
we learn about it?
What might we read?
Well I'll tell you: we read
letters, and we read diaries--
see now, their dead, so it's okay
for us to read their diaries--
so you have to save those
letters, and save those diaries,
for us to know what's in them.
And for the women, a lot
of people didn't save them.
So you really have to look hard
to find out what they were doing.
And so, it's hard work to write
the book, but it's really great
to see it once it's done.
Yeah?
>> We do have a question
from Arkansas.
We have a different elementary
school, Oak Grove, so Logan wants
to know:"why did they want to
steal the picture of Washington?"
>> Cokie Roberts: They wanted to
steal the picture of Washington
because Washington was the leader of
the country, and everyone knew that.
So sometimes, still today you'll
see when someone is overthrown
in a country their government falls.
For instance, in Iraq
when Saddam Hussein--
I guess you all are still
too young for that now--
he was ousted, they
toppled his statue.
And that has happened in America
during the Revolutionary war.
King George's statue
was up in New York,
and the Americans toppled
it, and sent it flying.
So King George hit the dust.
And so, the British wanted to
retaliate, wanted to fight back,
and I wanted to take
George Washington's picture
and show the Americans that their
leader no longer had a place
of honor.
At Dolly Madison made
sure that didn't happen.
>> Did all of those
people in the books,
did all of them have
a disease, or...?
>> Cokie Roberts: no, they
didn't all have a disease.
But diseases would happen.
And so, sometimes something like
yellow fever, which doesn't exist
in America anymore, thank
goodness, would calm
and then people would
get sick like that.
Not everybody had it, but you'd
sometimes have something happen
where everybody in town, where a
lot of people in town would get sick
and it would be very very hard.
>> Jamal's got another question.
>> Cokie Roberts: Okay.
>> Jamal: why did they want to
take charge Washington's picture,
but why did they want to take
the lady's picture instead
of George Washington's?
>> Cokie Roberts: so they couldn't
take George Washington's picture
because it was gone, she had made
sure that it wasn't there anymore.
It was on a carriage
on the way out of town.
But her picture was there, and
they were trying to find something
that they could mess with.
And so they took her
picture and destroyed it.
>> we have a question from Avery in
fourth grade, West Fork Elementary.
The question is:" how
much research did you have
to do to write this book?"
>> Cokie Roberts: Lots, and
lots, and lots of research.
And as I said earlier it
wasn't that easy to do.
And some of it is that
people didn't think
that women were important
enough to save their letters,
but some of it is that the women
or their husbands,
burned their letters.
So after George Washington died,
for instance, Martha burned all
of her letters between
herself and George.
Which I could kill her for,
if she weren't already dead.
We think she thought that
they were just too personal,
and that she didn't want people
reading her personal mail later.
So we only have a very
few of her letters.
But, another woman, the wife
of our second president,
who was John Adams.
John Adams was in the Congress
leading up to the Revolutionary war,
and he then became America's--
the person who spoke for America
in Europe and Holland,
and France, and England--
and because of that he was
away a lot of the time.
And so his wife, Abigail Adams,
wrote to him all the time.
And fortunately, he
saved her letters.
And we have thousands of
their letters to each other.
And they tell us very,
very interesting stories.
And then her son, who was-- what
this tells you, is when her husband,
hen John Adams was in the Congress
that was writing the Declaration
of Independence, it
was in Philadelphia,
and she was in Massachusetts,
where the British were.
And it was really dangerous.
And at one point, John wrote to her
and said "if it gets
really dangerous,
take our children and
fly to the woods."
Thank you John, I hope you're having
a nice dinner in Philadelphia.
But her son, John Quincy Adams, who
also of course became president,
to diary every single day.
And we have everything
that he wrote,
so he wrote about his
mother as well.
And so we can learn
about her from him,
and so that's the way
we do the research.
But it's not easy, it can be very,
very difficult to get
the information.
Okay, do we have any more from afar?
>> We do have a lot, actually.
So let's go back to Pennsylvania.
Pine Road elementary school.
So we have Madeleine who is in
third grade,Pine Rd., Elementary,
just to make sure we got that."
what other children's
books have you written?"
>> Cokie Roberts: These are the only
two children's books I've written.
I've written a bunch of grown-up
books, the ones with these names.
And then a book called " We
Are Our Mother's Daughters",
and a book called "From
This Day Forward".
And a book called "Capital Dames".
And then a book about
the Jewish Passover,
celebrated with interfaith
families "Our Haggadah".
So, a bunch of books, in all, but
just these two children's books.
>> Pam Jackson: Kind of a follow-up
question from the same school.
What inspired you to become
an author for children?
>> Cokie Roberts: well I became an
author kind of almost by accident,
because I work as Dr. Hayden
said, I work covering the news.
And it's a lot of work,
and it takes a lot of time.
And I really didn't think I
had time to do anything else,
because I also raised a
family, but a publisher came
to me and said "write a book".
And I said "what book?",
And she said "oh you are
bound to have a book."
and I said "I actually
don't have a book".
And so she said "well,
think about it,
you know you've probably
written some articles,
and given some talks
that could be a book."
and I said " well okay,
I'll think about it."
So I did, I put together
a lot of those things
and some interesting interviews with
people and I wrote a book called
"We Are Our Mother's Daughter's".
And that book did very,
very, very well.
And so the publisher wanted me to
come back and write some more books.
And so then my interest in
history really got me writing the
other books.
And then I discovered, even as hard
as it is, and it really is hard,
that writing books is
incredibly satisfying.
And so, I just keep doing it, even
though I still have a day job.
Yeah, Go ahead.
[ background conversation ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Well she's
had a lot, can we just, yeah,
this gentleman here who's
looking for a question?
You don't have a question?
Okay how about one
more from them, then?
>> How about, we have yet
another school in Arkansas,
this is from a librarian at Sparkman
school in Sparkman, Arkansas.
The fourth grade student,
Lane, who wants to know:"
when you began writing the book, and
if you'll be writing another book
about influential women of today?"
>> Cokie Roberts: Not of today,
because I write about people
who are alive for my regular
work, and they'll get mad at you.
So I don't want to write
about living people in books.
But I probably will
write another book,
and what's on my mind I
haven't 100 percent decided yet,
is the fact that we're soon going
to be celebrating the
hundreth anniversary
of women getting the right to vote.
And not much has been
written about the end of that,
when women actually got
the Congress to approve
of the amendment they gave us the
right to vote, and then having to go
after the states, and
get the states to do it.
There's been nothing that's written
about what's called
"ratification" will.
And so, that's probably
my next book.
But I haven't done it yet,
because I'm so busy right
now, with our new president.
He's taking up a lot of my time.
>> How did you know all
the faces of the women
that were in your two books?
>> Cokie Roberts: The faces?
Is that your question?
Yup.So that's a very good question
because of course we
didn't have cameras then,
so there were no photographs
of the women.
So what we have for most of them
is someone did a painting of them.
So it's copied after the paintings,
and that's true for
most of these women.
But for a couple of them we really
don't have what they look like.
Like this woman, who was very
early in our history, whose sons--
her name is Eliza Lucas Pinckney--
her sons were both in the
revolution, became great statesmen,
and she was brilliant herself.
When she was 16 years old
her father left her in charge
of two plantations
in South Carolina.
So we have all of her writing, but
there was never a portrait of her.
What we do have, and travels around
sometimes, is a dress of hers.
So we know how big she was,
but she started making
silk and made a dress.
And so we have that, but we don't
really know exactly what she
look like.
So it's a very good question.
And then in this book we have
this very interesting woman,
Lucy Terry Prince, who we think
wrote the first African-American
poem, or composed it,
and again she was written
about in all the newspapers, which
was really unusual for any woman,
but particularly a
formally enslaved woman.
But she was brilliant, and she
conducted arguments that she won,
and she was known, very well known,
but we don't really know
what she look like either.
But for the rest of
them we have paintings.
Will thank you also much for
coming, Dr. Hayden I'm sure wants to
>> Carla Hayden:Well we want to
thank Ms. Roberts, can we thank her?
[ applause ]
And and we want to thank
our friends in Arkansas
and Pennsylvania, and
tell them goodbye.
[ children in Unison ]
>> Bye!
And thank "Everybody Wins",
and miss Robert thank you
for making history come alive.
>> Cokie Roberts: Well
thank you so much
>> Carla Hayden: We hope
you come back again.
>> Cokie Roberts: Thank
you all, be at the Library
of Congress as often as possible.
>> Carla Hayden: Good.
>> Cokie Roberts: Thank
you, thank you kids!
Thank you!
>> Carla Hayben: Thank you!
[ applause ]
>> This is the presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.